let's go next to our caller from the
5:04 area code who do we have today
calling from five-0 for Virginia how you
doing good did you say Charlie and
Fairfax yeah that's right go ahead
charlie what's going on yeah they're
sort of unrelated but they're both
campaign finance questions and sort of
under the radar right now I think what
is with Donald Trump he's raised a ton
of money the Republican National
Committee's raised a ton of money if
he's somehow impeached and not the
candidate in 2020 where would that money
go and who would that be most likely to
benefit and then the other under the
radar question is if cryptocurrency and
Bitcoin become a popular means of
raising money for Kane and and there's a
big fluctuation in price going into 2020
could there be some unexpected benefits
to certain candidates are candidates
accepting Bitcoin donations I'm unaware
of that I know Andrew yang is a big
supporter of Bitcoin I had seen at one
point that he was trying to I think
accept Bitcoin for donations but I think
that was taken down or it might have
been a like a PAC they're not actually
his campaign that was doing it but there
could be money coming in through those
means okay yeah but it could be I don't
know that there is so on that basis I
don't know that it's going to make a
difference if Bitcoin goes goes up or
down if candidates are not actually
accepting that money I don't know
legally if they can I don't know
you know there's disclosures that need
to be done so I don't think that that's
really gonna make a difference okay I
know that in Virginia at least as far as
the the state board that governs
election and campaign finance they have
said that
are allowed to accept Bitcoin and
cryptocurrency and I think if it's if
it's you know donated when it's at a
certain value then if it appreciates it
appreciates I agree with you that's that
speculative I'm really more interested
in the more realistic possibility of
what could happen with all that
Republican model so so explain again
what could happen with the Republican
money if what so Donald Trump has raised
a ton of money for his 2020 campaign
yeah but what happens if he ends up
somehow not being the candidate where
does that money go and how much was
controlled by him how much is controlled
by the Republican National Committee and
could it be funneled to another
candidate I think that it could be
funneled to another candidate if Trump
first turns it over to the Republican
National Committee i I don't think that
that is going to be an issue but there
are campaign finance laws which I think
we could probably just google that that
would be much more accurate than my
recollection of it thank you for the
call I appreciate not equipped to give
you probably specific enough answers